[Music]
the one thing you need if you want to
move higher
is a greater awareness
[Music]
people are not earning a hundred
thousand a year because they want to
earn a hundred thousand a year they're
earning a hundred thousand a year
because they're not aware of how to earn
a hundred thousand a month
people aren't alone and lonely because
they enjoy being alone and lonely
they're alone and lonely because they're
not aware of how to build meaningful
relationships
people don't struggle all of their
commercial career
because they enjoy struggling they're
struggling because they're not aware of
how to knock those blocks down that are
all inside it's never outside it's never
another person it's never a condition or
a circumstance
it's always lack of awareness
this is such beautiful information
i've been living with it for a long time
i don't even know how you'd live without
it
in fact i don't think you can you merely
exist and unfortunately that's the way
most people go through life
do you see our educational institutions
is not giving us the same kind of
information they really don't they
really believe the secret is read the
book
remember what's in the book and be able
to repeat it answer the questions
more right than wrong you'll pass you
get the degree well we've got people
graduating from some of the most
prestigious universities in the world
every year
with multiple degrees
having difficulty finding work
that are broke how does that happen
and yet you'll find other people who are
functionally illiterate they can either
read or write they're earning millions
how do we account for this
you're going to find that out
as you study this
it's got nothing to do with anything
outside of ourselves
education isn't answering what's in the
book
education comes from the latin juco
meaning to reduce to developer to draw
from within remember i said everything's
already here omnipresent that's within
us
madam montessori was right
napoleon hill was right
carnegie knew the right question
hill knew how to answer it
what are you going to do with the rest
of your life
that's your question
you're going to make a decision
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
bob proctor and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy
rule number two desire to grow what's
the thing you want to learn and
understand that you feel like you know
what i haven't fully grasped this
concept or idea and i really want to get
to another level
well i'm always wanting to get to
another level hopefully i'm at a higher
level today than i was yesterday i i'm
in here
around 5 30 every morning studying wow
that's how i start my day here well
you see
there is no end to the growth
you you always want to grow so
you're created in god's image
now there's a problem with this
because we're raised on our physical
senses
we grow up
and what we've done is had god created
in our image in our mind
not that we're creating god's image
we're taught that we created god
in our image
so now we're trying to figure out how
can the man be omnipresent
how can that person be everywhere and
because we're locked in on a physical
level we get lost
when we understand
that you have infinite potential
there is no top
there's no beginning no end
see when it comes to school of greatness
there is no finish line
when it comes to personal development
there is no finish line
so how can you tell how well you're
doing by the results you're getting
by their fruits by their food you'll
know them by the results they're getting
if they're not getting the results they
don't know
so if you're going to get a mentor get
somebody that's getting the results yeah
or you don't want them rule number three
put money to use you see here on page
six it says money is a servant
it's a servant
now there's a myth about money
says another myth about money like you
accept money is that it only comes as a
result of luck or good fortune
well of course that is really silly
that's not true at all but that's the
concept that a lot of people operate
with
okay
now if you move over onto page seven
we're talking about money's got to
circulate it's not only a server you got
to keep it moving
i have some money here in my pocket
i keep in a little envelope
and
this stuff here
is money
the truth is this represents money
now this used to be paper now i think
it's plastic you know use it as a fan
but this is
it's a servant and you can put this to
work
you got to keep it circulating
now we tell a story in here
about
mr chapman now mr chapman was an
interesting guy
he lived on the street that i lived on
as a little boy
and my brother and i had a paper route
and we sold papers to the people on that
street we had 300 customers went right
from kingston road to the lake ontario
and almost every house we had as a
customer
mr chapman had a big house not too far
from our house up on a hill it was an
old house
and one day mr chapman we used to feel
sorry for him he was he was hunched back
he was a little man he used to push a
little cart around and he collected junk
his wife was a a tall thin lady
and
she always wore
just
skimpy clothes like
a cotton dress with a maybe a little
coat running shoes
and she would be off up the street she
went to clean houses or clean offices
we thought they were really poor
well one day we opened the paper we went
up the corner to get the papers and when
we got the delivery of the papers it was
headlines that mr chapman had died
it was a headline in the toronto star
they found a hundred thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars in a jar in the
house here he is collecting junk and he
had a hundred thousand dollars in a jar
in the house
now i just looked up that that up this
morning that's equal to one million
eighty seven thousand seven hundred
ninety eight dollars in today's dollars
that's what a hundred thousand in 1947
would have been uh in today's dollars
it'd be over a million a million eighty
seven
eighty eight thousand
he had all this money and he had it in a
jar
it was serving no one it wasn't
circulating
and we were shocked that he even had it
so
what we've got to understand
is that saving it like that is silly
like here the money that's in this
envelope in my pocket it's useless as
long as it's in an envelope in my pocket
it does no one any good
you may be saying why are you keeping it
there it won't stay
it won't stay there very long i'll have
it circulating in a very short period of
time
now if you come down to the bottom of
page nine these are just basics we're
talking about here about a prosperity
consciousness exercise
now that we have touched upon some of
the characteristics of money let us turn
briefly to a simple technique
which you can begin using immediately to
start attracting the amount of money
that you desire now think of that
you can literally attract to you
the amount of money you desire you've
got to ask yourself
where do i stand with money rule number
four stop
worrying first of all the cause of fear
is
ignorance
that is the cause of fear
and so if you follow the ignorance it
doesn't start out as fear
the ignorance starts out in a conscious
level as doubt and worry
on a conscious level we're doubting or
we're worrying then we take whatever
image comes into our consciousness of
the doubt and the worry and we turn it
over to our emotional mind that's what
causes the fear well that fear then has
to be expressed through the body to the
only instrument it can be expressed
through our physical body it sets up a
vibration known as anxiety
anxiety is not expressed anxiety becomes
suppressed
we suppress it
and the suppression then turns to
depression
which turns to disease which turns to
decay you see you're talking about a
track a person gets on it's a very
negative track
it's ignorance
don't worry
fear
anxiety suppression depression disease
disintegration
now the polar opposite of all that
the opposite of ignorance is knowledge
there's only one way to get to knowledge
and that is to study
now unfortunately
um
school
didn't do the job that it was designed
to do for most of us
schools should teach us to love to study
not to dread studying at homework and
test
they should teach us to love it
because study leads to the opposite of
don't worry which is understanding
see it's study that leads to
understanding we understand how to
handle the fear
it's understanding
that enables us to cause us to
understand where the fear starts
the understanding
then
we want to say what do we understand we
want to understand this whole universe
operates by law
one of the laws is the law of opposite
the opposite of don't worry is
understanding
now if the don't worry leads to fear
what's understanding leads to
understanding leads to faith
the faith leads to
expression
well-being and expression
it's not depression
it's not suppression it's not anxiety
the faith leads to well-being
the well-being then is expression
acceleration because we're at ease we're
not at there's not disease so you're
dealing with polar opposites there's two
different sides to things
and when we understand that
our world starts to change
just by understanding that that we learn
how to deal with these
pandemics when they hit
and they will hit there will be others
there always has been all down through
history if you look back
there's been things like this happen in
the past
and unfortunately the masses are sort of
paralyzed by it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five adopt good habits it
said no amount of reading or memorizing
is going to make you successful it's the
understanding and application of why
south africa you're going to study this
i study it every day
every day
for at least an hour
sometimes more but at least an hour
it's a habit
habits something you do unconsciously
you don't even spend any time thinking
about it you just do it
you get dressed by habit
you shower comb wash your hair
habit
do you know good habits
automatically transform our life rule
number six discover who you are the
purpose of a goal is not to get
it's not to reach the goal
it's the awareness that you develop as
you go after it
you're learning who you are
it's becoming aware of who you are
yeah
i was in a seminar years and years ago
and uh there was a speaker bill gove
bill gove was considered the
frank sinatra of public speakers he was
incredible
he had a handheld mic
and he's looking at the audience and he
said
if i want to be free
i've got to be me
not to me i think you think i should be
not to me i think my kids think i should
be
not to me i think my wife thinks i
should be if i want to be free
i've got to be me
he said i better know who me is rule
number seven plant your idea so you're
building an idea
and you're planting it in universal
intelligence now when you do that
when you do that what you want to
understand
is that
you planted that idea
here
that idea then
is planted in universal intelligence so
it's drawing from anywhere
anything that's in harmony with it
you see this
is a vibration
it's a frequency
and we have put ourselves on a specific
frequency when you hold that idea when
you're emotionally involved that must be
expressed within through you whatever
you need is in the universe and this
idea is going to attract it to you
because the idea controls the vibration
that you're in the vibration you're in
controls what you how you act but it
also controls what you attract
this is very important you get this your
subconscious mind
is um
it's like universal intelligence
and
that idea then
is on a specific frequency
hold on
we're spiritual beings
this is the spiritual side of you now
everything spirit
the intellect and the physical
but when you plant the idea here
it's planted on a specific frequency
it's almost like when i phone somebody
what i'm doing is i'm tuning in on a
particular frequency
and they're on that frequency
and when i press a number their phone
rings doesn't matter where they are
they could be anywhere in the world you
see when it comes to universal
intelligence you eliminate all time and
space there's no such thing as time and
space everything's in the now everything
is in the now
and it's important that we understand
that and when we understand it good
things start to happen to us
okay
now that idea
will attract to it
anything that's in harmony with it
so whatever you need will come to you
but it won't come to you before you need
it
and we're very impatient and we want to
do
this part before we get this part done
you got to do things in the order
you see this part is operating by law
it's operating by law
because it's universal intelligence and
the law is perpetual transportation of
energy that idea instantly begins to
move into form
and it attracts whatever is required but
it also causes you to act the way you
have to act so it's the action and
attraction that ultimately produces the
result
how long does it take for that to
manifest we don't know that's governed
by a law called law of gender that law
decrees that all things have a gestation
or an incubation period rule number
eight don't think in reverse
i want you
to stop and think of something you
really want
that maybe the thoughts on your mind
frequently that you really can't get
now let's clearly understand this is
what i've got on the screen here is what
we do far too often
far too often
we let the bank downs control our head
now i never let that happen
do you know why i never look at the
balance i've never balanced a checkbook
in my life i've never
and i don't intend to ever do it
i don't want to do it i think it's
terrible work
i don't want to do it now to some you
have to absolutely and i've got people
working with me there
sandy gallagher is a genius at this
she's just absolute genius and so i like
her being able to do what she's a genius
at i don't want to do it
i don't want to let results control my
thinking
i prefer to do this
now look here
i'm going to take this and this is what
i'd suggest you do and rub this out
rub present results out
and then start thinking here
we know that there's a power
that's flowing into our consciousness
we know that
and this power as it flows in
it just is
it's neither positive
or negative
it just is
and we can make out of it anything we
want
i've got the idea here
i'm not telling you what it is i'm going
to show you what it is
mikey and i are going to discuss it some
more
we get this idea here
now she's going to take this to the
marketing team
and they're going to start talking about
it
now let's understand this
you can do
what i'm suggesting here
and when you do this
you then become this this is you here
you become like you're magnetized
and and and you just it's like
whatever idea you hold
you impress upon your subject of mind
this is the part that you've got to try
and get straight
this part here
okay
your subconscious mind
is part of everything
everything's hooked together remember i
say the
love is a vibration there's no line of
demarcation they're all joined together
each one is hooked up to the one above
and the one below that's everything in
the universe is connected like that
now
and you can change it you have the
creative ability to change it
you see this here here's an hourglass
the sand in the glass
is running here it never stops
the glass that's holding the sand used
to be sand
now think what i'm saying
the glass that's holding the sand used
to be sand
but we have learned how to alter the
molecular structure change the vibratory
rate of the energy that we call sand and
we can turn it into glass then we can
mold it whatever way we want we can make
an hourglass out of it
it's energy the energy that we call that
is glass we call this sand because of
the vibration it's in we call this wood
because of the vibration it's in
okay we call this skin we call this hair
we call this cloth
it's all energy and it vibrates
everything is hooked together because
every frequency is connected to one
above and one below
when you get emotionally involved
with an idea and you really get it to
sink into your consciousness
you move your body into a vibration but
the mind body is in the vibration and
you are in sync intellectually
emotionally and physically the
consciousness and the subconscious in
the body all the same vibration
you have a strong a strong attractive
force setup
and that is strong attractive force is
going to start attracting to you
from every side of the universe
whatever is necessary
to manifest that idea
in physical form or in results
that is the result you want to see not
the not the one that exists now
when you look at the present result
that's thinking in reverse and that's
what this night chapter 9 is about most
people think in reverse do not think in
reverse quit looking backwards
it's a waste of time and a waste of
energy and it's very destructive for
your own future rule number nine be
willing to do it the only criteria you
have to have when you set a goal is do
you want it
do you want it doesn't matter how you're
going to do it it doesn't matter where
their money's coming from
i once heard a great story where the
maharashi when he was taking
transcendental meditation or decided he
was going to take him to the world one
of his close associates said
where's the money going to come from he
said wherever it is right now
i always thought it was such a beautiful
answer because the truth
everything you need
everything you want is already here
nothing is created or destroyed i didn't
dream this up it's the way it is all
science all theology tell us that the
way to get the moon was already here
always here when president john kennedy
asked dr warner von braun who's
considered the
father of space travel what it would
take to build a rocket that would carry
a man to the moon and bring him back
safely to earth
von braun answered him in five words the
will to do it
the will to do it will
is a mental faculty that gives us the
ability to concentrate you've got to
concentrate on what you want that's all
you can concentrate on
and that will keep you on the frequency
that you have to be on to attract
everything that you need to get there
this is so
important to see i believe decision
where it all starts
it's where it all started for napoleon
hill
it all started when carnegie asked him
are you prepared
to dedicate the rest of your life to an
idea for which you'll probably receive
no material compensation
for at least 20 years how would you
answer that
you see he didn't know how to do that
he didn't even believe he could
do you know what i found
when you set a goal you don't have to
believe it
if you keep repeating it you'll come to
believe it
if you tell yourself a lie often enough
you'll believe it
way back in 1900 william james from
harvard he said believe and your belief
will create the fact
so true
so true and so misunderstood
so what do you want
compare your dream
to napoleon hill's idea
just compare it for a moment
your idea is probably small by
comparison
but if you don't know how to do it if
you don't know where the money's coming
from if you don't know where the help is
going to come from
you'll probably seem large
when i took my pen
and i sat down and i wrote i would build
a company that operated all over the
world
i had no idea how i was going to do it i
certainly didn't have the finances to it
i didn't have the help i didn't even
have an assistant
i was just me in my den
writing on a pad
do you know something
today
i own a company
along with sandy gallagher who is my
business partner and we operate all over
the world
these aren't accidents
i'm just an ordinary guy
that's doing what the public would
consider something extraordinary but
it's not extraordinary to me and it's
not going to be to you when you start to
understand these principles and
incorporate them into your life i
mentioned we want to build schools in
africa
for kids that have never seen a school
and so we're building them
there's many things we want to do we do
them all i never wonder if i can do
something
i just ask myself do i want to
that's why i think god meant us to live
i believe we're doing god's work
somebody said what's god's word god well
if god's a creator then god's work would
be creation we've been given the mental
faculties to create
we've been created in god's image
somewhere along the line way back when
somebody got that mixed up
[Music]
they thought when they said you're
creating god's image that god was
created in their image so they're
looking for a man on a cloud there is no
man on a cloud
but i'm going to tell you something
you got some phenomenal stuff locked up
inside of you
you bring it to the surface
you can have anything you want
it's a great way to live and rule number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus clips is have fun the world is
mine it can be yours my friend
whenever you pretend pretend you're
happy when you're blue
it isn't very hard to do
and you'll find happiness without an end
whenever you pretend
if i take the areas where i'm a little
six bit short i'm just not really very
good and i didn't go to school so
there's a lot of areas
i'm gonna get the very best
and i'm gonna do exactly what they tell
me
and that's what i did when the man who
gave me this book he said do exactly
what i'm telling you
i did exactly what he said
15 years or so ago
and
well first of all
he became my mentor
and a very good friend read up until he
passed away
our company was having financial
problems all the time
and i could earn all kinds of money but
i don't know how to manage it i wasn't
gonna know how to run a company i mean i
wasn't designed for that
and i didn't want to learn it i didn't
even like the subject
but what you need you will attract
and we had a lady come to seminar was a
securities attorney
she fell in love with what we were doing
she was a
a full partner in a company
and
over a period of time she became my
business partner she owns half the
company
but she's the she runs the company she's
the president chief executive
of the company
i mentioned her last time you should get
around for an interview sometime because
she is a fascinating person but she does
a phenomenal job here yeah well so i
have found in the areas that i'm not
really good at
i get the very best
and i work with them i don't try and
learn what they're teaching
i get them to do that i get somebody
else to do something else because it's
going to take me to where i want to go i
have a young guy here that runs our
studio
he's the director of the studio he he's
absolutely brilliant
he set a goal when he was 13 to work
with me i remember this he was living in
manchester and england and he watched
the secret and he saw me he said i'm
going to work with him
13 years later he's here in the studio
and he runs this place i love that he's
incredible
he can record and send it from anywhere
in the world he can come in here and do
everything and i found that's one of the
secrets of getting to where you wanna go
you need help you gotta have help you
gotta have a lot of help you're saying
we can't just do it all on our own bob
never gonna do it on your own
it won't go very far if you're doing it
alone love is the greatest thing
love what you do
i went to visit earl nightingale one
time way back in the 60s i'll never
forget it and i was leaving i felt i was
so grateful i had an hour of his time
and i said earl
what's the real secret i mean what's the
big deal well he said there isn't a big
deal about him and there isn't any
sacred it's
simply a matter of sitting down and
determining what you really love to do
and then make a decision to dedicate
your life to it
man did i get excited
he said the problem with most people is
they don't know what to do and they
never make a decision to dedicate their
life to anything
i got so jazzed i knew exactly what i
would love doing i would love to do what
he was doing that made up my mind i
wanted to do it and i wanted to do it
with him and i made up my mind i would
make a commitment to that for the rest
of my life you know something that's
exactly what i've done i love what i'm
doing i love it i absolutely love it now
when you love doing something you'll run
baby and you won't get weary you'll walk
and you won't get tired you know why
you're a free flow the energy is just
freely flowing through you
you are the greatest instrument then
that god's got you're here to do god's
work
what's god's word god's work is creation
god's the creator
you're creating god's image you've been
given creative faculties
fall in love with what you do and you'll
be creating great stuff wherever you go
love what you do
love the people that you're working with
fall in love with the idea of love at a
very early age we put a cap on awareness
and then we say now it's all about the
intellect
and so we've got
lessons in school and you've got to
remember what's in the book and if you
pass the test you get the degree
there's all kinds of people walking out
of schools with degrees they're going
crazy by degrees and yet they can't find
work they're broke
you've got people that have a doctor
it's in economics and they're broke how
could that happen because they don't
know how to use the information they've
gathered the average individual is
self-serving they're they're they're
always focused on themselves i want you
to just pay conscious attention today
write a little note maybe that you fold
up and carry in your hand why do you do
that just to remind you that you want to
pay attention to everybody you meet what
are they doing
are they really trying to help other
people or are they really trying to find
help for themselves are they
self-serving or are they serving others
you're going to find the people that are
the best at serving others
they are the big winners in life
figure out how you can improve the
service you're rendering
now i'm probably a little older than you
so i've been running around the park for
quite a while longer than you
and i have learned one thing
really well in life
that my success my happiness is going to
be dependent on how good i get at
serving you or serving other people
i spend most of my time trying to figure
out how to help other people
i do
i don't spend much time you know
i get almost everything i want
almost everything i want there's very
few things i can't even think of
anything i want christmas birthday comes
along well i don't know and
you know
send a donation in my name i like i
don't want anything
[Music]
it's got to a point where i just want to
serve others
so i want to do is serve others
now i'm a pretty happy guy
pretty healthy guy pretty wealthy guy
what have i done i have just learned how
to fall in love with the idea of serving
other people
our company's success is going to be
dependent upon how many people we can
serve and how well we serve them
we have a phenomenal staff of people in
proctor gallagher institute i choose to
believe that we have
i just i just love our staff
we have some of the most phenomenal
people
and we've got people come like we have a
guy tommy collier the guy is a creative
genius he came he wanted to come to work
with us you want to work with us
i thought wow guys so good
you will attract
good people if that's all you want to do
just serve other people that's what we
do and we've got everybody in the
company that's where they're going we've
got some pretty happy people very
successful people and all we did is
focus on serving other people companies
that are enjoying the most success
they're the ones that provide the most
the best service
it's the way it works
it always has worked that way
and i'm inclined to believe that it
always will work that way
fall in love with the idea of serving
others
you'll be very happy but you'll also be
very successful j.c penney when he was
92 somebody asked him
how you doing
well he said my eyesight is fading me
but he said my vision has never been
better
[Music]
van gogh one time was asked how do you
do such beautiful work
he said
i dream my painting
and then i paint my dream
vision
vision
where there is no vision the people will
perish
what is vision
vision
is a
long-range view of a multiplicity of
things you want to do
[Music]
now your purpose is why you're living
your vision then you want everything to
be on purpose your vision then is like a
funnel coming out of your head going off
out into the future it's a long range
picture of a multiplicity of things you
want to do
your goal is taking a bite out of your
vision
so sit and think i'm god's highest form
of creation i've got mental faculties
that go beyond the scope of my
imagination
and build a long-range vision
of all the magnificent things you want
to do
live with a vision
[Music]
if you're not doing that now you're
missing something in life that's very
valuable
stop whatever you're doing right now and
totally relax and build a vision of
doing all kinds of things in the future
future they all blend in together but
they're all different and your life just
keeps getting bigger and better and
bigger and better and bigger and better
[Music]
that's the vision of your life
vision it's a beautiful picture it's
like a movie in your mind
a vision
you build the vision with your
imagination
not with your eyes
but with your imagination
see a person hasn't got this
where there is no vision the people will
perish
it's so true
so true
television i quoted andrew carnegie a
few minutes ago
he said any idea that's held in the mind
that's emphasized that's either feared
or revered
begins at once to clothe itself in the
most convenient and appropriate form
available
depression
comes it starts out from ignorance doubt
and
worry i've got a chart i show it
doubt and worry
is on the negative side of life
understanding is on the positive side
don't worry comes from ignorance
understanding comes from knowledge but
you've got to study to get it
don't in worry are a psychic disease
it's an intellectual exercise
they're using their intellectual factors
to build a negative idea
and that's all they see
they take and internalize that and they
get emotionally involved with it it goes
from don't worry to fear
they've emotionalized the doubt or worry
turns into fear
the fear is in the emotional mind and
the emotion must be expressed through
the only instrument that can be
expressed through the physical body
so it moves a body into a state we call
anxiety
anxiety is never expressed anxiety
suppressed
the suppression turns to depression
they've all led up inside they
suppressed the fear
it turns into depression the depression
turns into disease
the disease turns into decay sinclair
lewis was right he said we don't die we
kill ourselves now what is the opposite
of all that you go from ignorance to
don't worry to fear
anxiety suppression depression disease
disintegration go over on the other side
you go from understanding
to emotional state called faith
you just know it's going to move into
form because you understand the law
faith doesn't believe in something you
can't see
strange thing about faith and fear they
both demand you believe something you
can't see
why would people choose fear over faith
because they're ignorant
so you go from understanding to faith
the faith manifests on the physical
plane not as anxiety as well-being
the well-being is not suppressed it's
expressed
and the expression turns to acceleration
you're building energy
and that is because there's no disease
you're at ease
and that turns into creation not
disintegration
it's all it's all a mental trip that
they're building
now they go to the doctor the doctor
gives them valium or some kind of drug
to cool them out
he gets them numb so they don't know
what the hell they're doing have you
ever thought of
failing
your way to success
think about that for a moment do you
know that anyone that enjoys any kind of
success feels their way there
that's right they do
i want you to think of this for a moment
see this little light here
someone gave me this as a gift this is a
replica
of the light that
edison built
and you know
he spent a long time before he got this
thing to glow he really did
and
[Music]
he started off because he had an image
of it in his mind that every time he
tried he failed
and he failed three thousand times it's
been said no i've never really talked to
edison so i don't know if that's
accurate but i have an idea it is
three thousand failures
now a reporter asked him one time how he
felt about failing three thousand times
he said i didn't fail three thousand
times
he's there with three thousand steps to
get to where i'm going
you know if i were to tell you
all the sad stories about
it's got me to where i am
i would really spoil your week and
there's been some real sad stories
i think it might even make me cry again
but i've had so many failures that i
wouldn't even want to guess at it
i have
i've blown everything i had three
different times
i never let it bother me much and you
know i have found that
every time i failed
i moved closer to the goal
you see if you knew how to do it now
you'd be going sideways when you're
going after a goal you're going ahead
and because you're going where you've
never been you're going to make mistakes
you don't know it all you have
perfection within you and the objective
of life is to
bring that perfection to the surface
that's exactly what this guy did
well
you're going to make a lot of mistakes
bringing that to the surface
those mistakes
are steps to where you're going
i often tell sales people that are
afraid to make a call
just to get out there and make a call
and their objective isn't to sell their
objective is just make the call
if you make the call and you're afraid
and you do it
you're successful you've accomplished
what you want to do you made a call
and after you get comfortable making
those calls then you can start to polish
up your presentation
and odds are pretty good you'll start
making sales
and if you keep polishing up your
presentation and working at getting
better you're going to master
a thing called selling
[Music]
but if you think
that you're going to enjoy great success
there's just one win after another
you're kidding yourself it just doesn't
happen i don't even know anyone that's
pulled that kind of a deal off
if they did they were cheating or lying
you don't get what you want you get what
you are
you've got to become what you want
you've got to realize that the minute
you hold your mind in harmony with the
good you want
then you've already got it it's only a
period of time until it manifests in
physical form you've got it
intellectually and you can talk to
somebody about it you've got it
emotionally you can share your feelings
it's only a period of time until it
moves into form that's called the
perpetual transmutation of energy
that is a law the first law of the
universe do you have any regrets for
your life
no
absolutely not
i'll tell you
okay
i probably would have said yes
15 20 years ago
then what happened
i was watching johnny carson's show
the late show
and johnny carson wasn't there
george carlin the comedian was sitting
in for him
and
they're both dead now
vincent price a movie actor
was a guest he's gone too
but vincent price
had just shot a pilot
and of course they told the public on
television it's a new series well it
wasn't a new series at all they were
hoping it would turn into a new series
they shot a pilot if they got good
ratings then they'd shoot
a dozen more of them right and
so after they went through the small
talk carl and says to him well tell me
vince
vincent tell me about our new your new
series
convince says oh i think everybody's
going to love it
he said it's about a train and it's like
a magic train
is you can buy a ticket
to go back in your life
i would pay for that any point you want
to start over
and he said when you get there i'm the
conductor on the train i stopped the
train now you off
and he said i think everybody'd like to
go back and start over at some point
don't you think so
i thought yeah i could think of a couple
of things where i could have started
over
and george carlin said
no i don't think so
he said if i went back and changed
anything that had happened in my life
i wouldn't be me
and i like me
i thought god what a perfect answer
no regrets everything that happened was
necessary to make me who i am to
premiere prepare me to do what i'm going
to do
and you see the crazy part about it none
of us know what we're going to do we
think we know right we've got to track
but
things happen that barrier to science
well there's a couple of them okay i
think there's two barriers one is our
conditioning the conditioning that takes
place in our subconscious mind from the
time we're infants
all we can do is act and talk like the
people around us that's why we learn the
language we learned
if there was 10 languages spoken in our
home we'd learn 10 languages without any
trouble
there's usually one and that's the only
one we ever learn and we grow older and
we think well i couldn't learn another
language we could learn 100 if we wanted
to you can do anything but i think we're
conditioned we have a
real strong conditioning usually with
not some very good ideas
and then that that's the
the barrier that's inside is the one
that's outside of it says our
environment we have a tendency to act
like everybody around us
and if you think about this it doesn't
make a lot of sense because if you study
statistics 95 percent of the people live
their entire life and never live the way
they want to live
you know that 95 percent of the
population in this country let's say in
north america okay the richest continent
in the history of the world
they'll work productively let's say for
40 of their 65 years okay and they'll
end up with hardly any money
there's got to be something wrong you
know that most people don't reach their
goals
do you know there's a difference between
setting a goal and achieving a goal now
almost everyone knows how to set a goal
they go into their imagination they pick
out what they want they write it down
but you know something
90 some percent never reach it and i
know why
setting your goal is an intellectual
exercise it's using your higher
faculties
reaching a goal is lawful process
it's turning the idea over to the
universal subconscious mind you've got
to learn how to get these two parts of
your mind working in harmony to reach a
goal the future must become the present
in the imagination
of the one who had wisely and
consciously create circumstances
[Music]
i think right now everybody wants to
create circumstances because they don't
like the ones they find themselves in
but you see you cannot change the
circumstance you find yourself in
you can only change your perception of
them and when you do that you change the
circumstance so we say here the future
must become the present in the
imagination of the one who would wisely
unconsciously create circumstance we
must translate vision into being
[Music]
thinking of into thinking from
imagination must center itself in some
state and then view the world from that
state
see yourself where we want to be and
then be there
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world
of fulfilled desire
that is so cool
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world of fulfilled
desire
so what are we doing we're building a
goal
and then we see ourself already haven't
accomplished a goal
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world of fulfilled
desire already got it i don't have to
get it i've already got it
that's an intense perception
of the world of fulfilled desire in
other words you got it it's here
now think
are you thinking from the end or you're
thinking of the end if you're thinking
of the end you're thinking way out there
if you're thinking from the end you're
part of it
see
the end result has already happened in
our mind
we're creative beings we're god's
highest form of creation
we can create in our consciousness the
kind of person we want to be and then be
that person and that's what he said here
we must
translate vision into being
so we don't just visualize it we be it i
set a goal in 1973
i set a goal that i was going to build a
company and upgrade all over the world
i had uh left the nightingale cornet
corporation
and decided that
i was going to do this because i didn't
agree with the way they were doing it
people weren't really learning it fast
enough
they wouldn't get involved in the
repetition we were selling recordings
but the recordings weren't working
because the people didn't understand how
to use them
so i decided i would leave and start my
own company
and i wrote down i'd build a company and
operate all over the world i got a call
last night from mikey about nine o'clock
something like that
and then she told me
that we were now
in every country in the world
now think of that
we had a broadcast going on here at 10
o'clock this morning
some of you'd be familiar with some of
you may have been on it
and
that broadcast had attracted thousands
literally thousands of people
from every country in the world
the goal was reached
that move
meant this is really accurate today
we're only limited by weakness of
attention and poverty of imagination
well my imagination was pretty well
exercised i don't have any difficulty
building huge ideas in my mind and just
figuring out how to do it
now stay with me here
the thing that's stopping you
from taking the risk that you want to
take
is called a terror barrier
the way i'm going to explain this to you
i come up with sitting in a restaurant i
remember it was at a holiday inn
restaurant
it was at dixie and
just south of the 401 highway
in toronto
a man asked me if i would meet with him
he had a problem
and
i was going to show him how he could
solve the problem
and he explained it so i took a pen and
some paper and what i'm going to show
you here is essentially what i showed
him
now look at this for a moment
there is the process you go through
when you're in a risk-taking vibration
you go from
bondage to reason
to the terror barrier and then to
freedom
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier
and then the freedom i think reason is
probably
it's the one that's spoken about by
almost all the great leaders yeah um the
evolving complete unanimous agreement
that we become what we think about
it's our reasoning factor that enables
us to think
um
ford says thinking's the hardest work
there is which is the probable reason so
few people engage in it
dr ken mcfarland uh
who's gone for a long time now but he
was a great educator down in kentucky
he one time said two percent of the
people think three percent think they
think and 95 would actually rather die
than things
now you know that sounds cute
but it's true
if you stop and listen
to what most people are saying
it's going to be fairly obvious they're
not thinking
if you stand back and watch what most
people are doing
it's fairly obvious they're not thinking
or they would never say or do what
they're doing
most people today have their television
on the news
and they're just
soaking up all the stuff
that's going on that's dominating the
media right now
so they've become a play thing for
what's going on outside
and that's why they're living in such
fear
by consuming the media of whether it's
true or accurate or not true you're
you're being manipulated in that sense
yeah it's not a matter of whether it's
true or not
is this how you want to spend your life
just listening to that
and that doesn't mean you should deny it
it doesn't mean that you should say well
that's all false
um
i don't know whether it's true or false
it's just bad news i don't want to be
involved in it yeah am i aware that it's
there well you'd almost have to be dead
not to be aware that it's there but that
doesn't mean you have to spend your time
thinking on that
i would much rather activate some of my
creative faculties and
do something that's constructive it's
pretty well known today there's a lot of
fear in the world
people are wondering what's going to
happen we've gone through many tough
times if you study history
i was born during the great depression
i was of an age then i remember some of
the things as a little kid
then we went into a world war
and when the depression ended
it was sort of like a theater where the
lights were out it was empty but the
lights started to come up
and things started to get brighter
and of course they became very bright
so
the fear
don't let fear control you fear is a
negative emotion
by following these principles you're
going to be on the other side of fear
where there's faith
there's a law of the universe called
polarity
that law decrees everything has an
opposite
every negative has a positive
the truth is it's neither positive or
negative
it's our thinking that makes it so
everything just is we can make it what
we want
make up your mind now you're going to go
in the positive polarity you're going to
stay with me because that's where i'm
going
and there'll be a very bright future
let the fear go
it isn't necessary
the cause of it is ignorance the cause
of all fear is ignorance if you want
something you haven't got you've got to
create a space for it if it's in your
own mind you've got to let go of
something
so what do we want to do to let go if we
want to let go of the image we've got
for the one we're going to build
now
i'm going to be honest with you when i
started to do this
i tested it just
i thought i wonder if this really work
and i found that it really worked
so i went all
and
you start out by writing
the image that you want to hold
i'll tell you how i did it
i um
i took various people that i really
admired
and i took some of the qualities that i
really admired in them and i'd write
them down
i wasn't going to be like them but i was
going to develop a couple of these
qualities or habits when i was growing
up i was a young guy it was during the
second world war
there was no men around no fathers
but one guy did have a father donny
miller's father
had was not well so he couldn't go to
the war
um
donny's dad had a heart attack or
something it was i think it was a heart
attack
and so we never went around his place
because his dad wanted things quiet
they'd come around our place but not
donny's place
i would watch
donny's dad walk up and down the street
you see him go way up the street later
on you'd see him come back
he was always well dressed and he had
the calmest walk
there was no rush just a very calm walk
i visualize myself walking like him
you'll very rarely ever see me rushing
anywhere there's no need of it
you can be calm so when i built my
self-image
i built it around certain things ray
stanford
always had money
i told you earlier i don't know how to
get into this thing now
always have some money
always
now
i hardly ever use it
because i really don't pay for very much
i get somebody in the company to order
whatever i want
but you see i never had any money ray
always had a roll on him
he would have a roll like that in his
pocket all the time
now there's about three thousand dollars
here this is not about there is three
thousand dollars here
you see
well
i only earned four thousand dollars a
year at that time three thousand dollars
would have been a ton of
money
but
everybody has different little quirks
i like to carry money
i and it's probably because i never had
any
and now
i have some money i want to carry it but
you see i started to do that before i
had any money
and i would take
and i would put
phony money in a roll but i would have
the right thing on the outside it was
the thickness of it
my mind didn't know the difference i
knew intellectually the difference and
then shortly i didn't even pay any
difference to that it was the feel of it
i did different things i watched
different people i saw how this person
did this and somebody else did that
i am
i read a lot so i read a lot of great
self-help books
and
i literally did what some of these books
suggested
it wasn't just sometimes i did it
i would follow it right to a t um
you'll very rarely see me without a suit
on
that's part of the paradigm
that's part of the paradigm
i don't care what anybody else does how
they dress
i'm always going to be dressed
i um
mentally made up my mind one time i'd be
at least
if i wasn't the best dressed one of the
best race people in the room
why did i do that
i did that because i was changing how i
saw me
how i saw me i had never gone to school
i had no money i had
dumb jobs
and today
along with sandy gallagher i have a
company operates all over the world
right here on my desk i have sitting
this little
hourglass
well you know i can't put anything where
that hourglass is until i get rid of it
and we find that we want things to come
into our life but we don't create room
for them
nature
abhors a vacuum and i remember we were
sitting in the living room having a cup
of coffee
and just visiting and she said do you
mind if we go and sit in the kitchen
that's not at all
so
so i asked her i said
why do you want to sit in the kitchen
rather than she says i can't stand that
room i just hate living in that sitting
in that room she's i hate those curtains
that are on the window in the dining
room and the drapes on the front window
and i said no you don't hate those mark
i said you only have attract things to
you that you love that you're in harmony
with i said if you really didn't love
them you get rid of them
but she said i'm going to put that
i'm going to put them there if i get rid
of them i said marg
if you had something to put there you
couldn't put it there because you've
already got something there
and i said that's when i started
teaching the law
of vacuum law prosperity
certainly she went and got a chair and
got up and stood on she started to take
all these curtains down
well done he was wearing like a
stuffed peg he said what are you doing
and she says i'm getting rid of these
and she did
wasn't too long after i dropped in all
the furniture in the living room was
gone
it was like they were just moving into
the place
but then they got new curtains and then
they got new furniture and you know
everything in that business in that
house changed it wasn't too long they're
only in business for themselves they're
both gone now but when they left they
were very well off they had a beautiful
place in florida they'd go to the winter
the family still runs their own business
i mean it was it was such a beautiful
thing to see and it was all and i tell
the story in here because it was all
about the vacuum law of prosperity
well what have you got in your life that
you don't want
or that you don't like
or what is it that you've got that you
really want to get rid of you've got to
get rid of this stuff get rid of it give
it away
see nature truly does abhor a vacuum
when you make space for the good that
you desire that's when the goods going
to come most people don't make the space
for the good that they desire talk about
people paying themselves they pay
everything under the sun but they don't
pay themselves
think of when you're on a plane
and
the oxygen mask may drop down
there's a problem with oxygen in the
plane
they will tell you if you have a child
with you put your own on first
because you can't look after the kids if
you haven't got your self looked after
well that's exactly the same with money
look after yourself first if you don't
pay yourself
you're soon gonna
teach yourself and just not do very well
we are building a picture in our mind
here this is an idea
we could say it's a goal
then we impress that idea upon this part
of our personality
that's the idea in our mind
now what we've got to understand
is that
this part of our mind the subject of
mind
is actually universal intelligence
and this is really the way it is
when you press the id upon your
subconscious mind
you are
universally everywhere
now to help you think of that
where here's the phone
let's suppose you're in uh
and okay
buenos aires
and
i'm right here
in north america toronto
and i dial your number i've got you on
the phone
time in space means nothing because i've
got on to that frequency
and so you and i can communicate we're
connected
one person's in bonus errors or you
could say singapore you could say
shanghai and another one is in new york
or in toronto but they're connected why
the time and space means nothing
because you're dealing with energy
and you're dealing with laws
now when you impress this idea upon the
subconscious mind
the subconscious mind is universal
intelligence
and everything
anywhere in the universe
that's in harmony
that is a frequency understand that
that idea is a frequency
it's operating on a frequency
and so everything that's in harmony with
it
begins to move toward it
because then harmonious vibration and
you attract it
now
throw a slide up scott
look here for a moment
soren kikergaard
wrote something really great on
intuition
he said listen you got to listen you
listen with your emotions
we can only get in touch with our own
source of intuition and wisdom
when we no longer depend upon others
opinions for our sense of identity or
worth
we all tend to worship something
the question is
will we worship the god of opinion
or the god of our heart
i found i had less and less to say until
finally i became silent
and began to listen
i discovered in the silence
the voice of god
now look
at you're going to attract to you
everything that you require
to manifest the idea in your mind
thoughts will come to you
it's your intuition that picks them up
and then act on them
and just because you've never gone there
before you've never done it before
that's okay
this is where courage comes in
this is where awareness
and wisdom comes in
see intuition is the mental faculty
if go back to our slide here for a
moment scott
intuition is here
in our conscious mind
it's one of our intellectual factors
we have perception
the will
reason
imagination
memory and
intuition
right here
now intuition is that mental faculty on
a conscious level
we pick up thoughts
that are flying our way
they're flying our way
what are they
it's energy that's in harmony with you
you've got on the frequency
of this good that you desire
and you're going to start attracting and
that's what kierkegaard said we got to
start listening
we listen with our emotions let's pay
attention to what's coming our way i
didn't like the idea that
when you've lived for so long you've got
to cut out you've got to stop i thought
hell i don't like that idea at all
and
first of all i think we're
we're i believe we're here to do god's
work god's work is creation
you know
uh
expansion fuller expression greater
goodness
um
and if we're going to do that
we're going to be working at it
all the time we're here on this planet
we never stop
so age should have no bearing on it
mm-hmm
i had a gospel
when we started to build this place we
put a couple of million dollars into
this and somebody said how old are you
and i think i was probably 83 when they
started to break ground
they said you're 83 and you're gonna
spend two million dollars building a
studio
and i said yeah like
why not
i mean
you see we let things that
really have no concern we let them
bother us we let them control us
age is a dumb thing to let control you
it's our thinking that controls
everything
that's the one point every great leader
agreed on we become what we think about
well what's the person thinking
i'm thinking if i get old i got to stop
well then you'll stop
or i'm thinking well if i've been here a
long time i've got a lot of experience i
want to utilize that experience to keep
me going as long as i am here i want you
to think of this for a moment let's
suppose there was a virus going around
and this virus caused people to really
stunt their growth ruin their income and
caused them to mix with people who are
on the wrong track and it was a virus
and there didn't seem to be any
prescriptions to solve the problem we
would be in panic state we would be
looking everywhere for some kind of a
prescription to fix and kill this virus
well do you know that's what a paradigm
is a paradigm is a program that is
lodged in your subconscious mind in your
innate mind it has been placed there
genetically from the moment of
conception all mom's dna in all dad's
dna is your dna and then there's an
attractive force set up and when you are
born then your environment becomes part
of the paradigm why do you think so many
people are struggling why do you think
only three or four percent live a truly
faux wealthy meaningful life is because
everybody is caught up in the paradigm
when i started to study this when i
started to understand it it just about
blew my mind and then when i found out i
could change it i could take a pen and
write my own paradigm and live the way i
really wanted to live
i almost found it hard to believe sandy
gallagher is my business partner love
her
she is really good
she was going through a very tough time
personally
a number of years ago
we were in phoenix we were doing a
seminar
i had to leave
catch a plane somewhere
and she said before you leave
could we get together maybe for a cup of
coffee
could you um
i want to talk to you and i said sure
so we went across the road to a coffee
shop
and we were sitting there
and she said could you give me two or
three ideas that i could do every day
that would help me through this i said
sure i didn't know what i was going to
tell her but i knew i'd tell her
something
so i said every day
i want you
to take a pen
[Music]
and write down every morning write down
10 things you're grateful for
but you've really got to be grateful
you've got to feel it you're really
grateful
then i want you
to send love to three people that are
bothering you
they're bothering you you don't like
them
they've got nothing to do with it you're
thinking bad thoughts about them you're
putting yourself in a bad vibration send
love to three people that bother you
and then
take five minutes
and be quiet
just be perfectly quiet and ask for
guidance for the day
everybody in our company does that every
day
she started to do it like that
everything changed
[Music]
in fact my assistant gina who's been
with me over 30 years
she was working in phoenix and i phoned
jaina i told her what i wanted within an
hour she had a pad printed at kinko's
and had it
the ten things from one down to ten you
know
send love to three people and bother you
be quiet for five minutes
sandy was going to hawaii
with her sister and her mother the next
day
she got pads made for both of them and
every morning they started to do that it
changed every one of their lives
we give that out now in a lot of our
seminars and we train the audience to do
it
start every morning write ten things
that you're grateful for
send love to three people to bother you
[Music]
be quiet for five minutes and ask for
guidance for the day
it's a winning form you see the
beautiful truth is you've already got
everything you need inside
you don't have to get it
you don't have to follow the pattern
that our formal educational institutions
teach us
you don't have to read all the books
that's not necessary
i think madame montessori put it very
well she said we tend to send a child to
school
as if they're an empty cup and we expect
them to fill the cup
[Music]
she's the truth is the cup's already
full
school is to help draw what's already
there
you see you and i are god's highest form
of creation there's nothing on the
planet that will even come close to us
strange things you know you and i are
the only creature on the planet that is
totally disoriented in our environment
all those other little creatures they're
completely at home in their environment
they blend in
we don't
we're totally disoriented and that is
because we have the ability united of
creating our own environment
now think of what that means
that means that you and i can literally
create the life we want
now as i said when i first heard that i
did not believe it
but i knew the man that was giving me
the advice believed it and that man was
raymond douglas stanford one of my very
first mentors have you ever spent any
time wondering how does everything
happen
how does everything happen why does the
night follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the
day in fact in some places it does
but
[Music]
i spend a lot of time thinking about
this
in fact at times it almost drives me
crazy
but like right outside of my studio here
is a japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the bud bloom and leaves pop
out
and the leaves generally in the spring
are a very deep greeny brown they're not
a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're most
beautiful it is the most beautiful tree
and it's right outside in my studio
i'm sitting here in my desk and
the camera's around me but
out there is that tree
[Music]
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
every spring they're greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring they're always red in
the fall and greeny brown in the spring
think about it
did you ever wonder
why
the tide goes way out the tide comes way
back in
i spent some time in the navy in canada
i was down on the east coast for a while
and i was near the bay of fundy do you
know the bay of fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same up around prince george on the west
coast
you go onto a ship
and you might be walking up a plank just
right straight up and you go off the
ship sometimes you're going right down
that ship goes way up near and it comes
way down
very high very low tide now some place
the tide's not very big they do have a
tide but not too high not too low
why is it so different one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know
just stayed at a certain length you
wouldn't have to cut it but it would
always look pretty
you know
do you ever think about this do you know
that everything in this universe happens
in an exact way
an exact way
not by chance
but in an exact way
when john kennedy
the president of the united states acted
as dr warner von braun
who was the
mastermind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring him back
safely to earth
von braun answered him in five words the
will to do it that's it the will to do
it
he knew you didn't have to know how to
do it he knew you had to learn how to do
it but you didn't have to know
to make up your mind you were going to
do it now why did he say that because he
understands the laws
von braun one time said after years of
studying the spectacular mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of god and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise
that we don't even have any difficulty
building spaceship we send people to the
moon and we can time the landing with
the precision of a fraction of a second
now he said these laws must have been
set by someone i see the laws as god's
modus operandi but i'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law
when you and i
get in harmony with the law now we do
that odds are pretty good we should
understand them but when we get in
harmony with the law then i'm going to
tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
[Music]
probably be a good understand good idea
to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them i'm going to
shock yourself for the good you can do
now i've been doing that for the last 58
years i'm starting to get a really a
reasonable grip on them but i don't
understand them as well as i wanted to
or would like to
but i'm going to study a little more
today you know i get my
trusty book out here
i'll have to talk to you about this book
that'll be another talk
study the laws
find out what they write what they're
like
what are the laws and then study them
you'll win ever notice that some people
seem to want to hang on to stuff that is
bothering them they're forever talking
about it they don't want to let it go
they've had a a failure at something and
it's dwelling they can't get over it
they just can't get over or somebody
said something nasty to them they don't
want to let it go
do you know what we should do
we should ask ourselves everything that
happens is this serving me
is this serving me and if it's not
serving you get rid of it
you don't want anything in your life
that's not serving you that's not
causing you to grow that's not adding to
the quality of your life
i don't care what it is you will sign
some people they just hold on to bad
stuff they hold on to problems they
don't want to seem to let it go
and that adds more problems whatever you
focus on grows
the only thing that can grow is the
thing you give energy to
why would you hold on to anything that's
not serving you now i want you to think
about this i'm not going to talk about a
lot about this today because i don't
think i have to i just want to let you
know that if you're holding on to
something that does not serve you
you are making a terrible error it's
going to cause all kinds of problems you
may blame other people or other things
you may blame the situation
you are the cause of the problem
the man that
told me to pick up this book and read it
ray stanford
he had a saying he used to say to me
bob you're the only problem you'll ever
have and you're the only solution
i think it might have taken me five
years to understand that but i do
understand it
and you know something
i am the only problem i'll ever have and
i am the only solution
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you reject it
you know the beautiful part about having
an inductive reasoning factor
that's the part that chooses thoughts
you can accept or reject the beautiful
part of your mind you can accept or
reject anything that comes into your
world except to reject it it's a choice
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you i like there's a saying on
all of your seminars on the tickets
uh
if you have to borrow money for this
do it it may be the last time
you're doing it listen
when i when i read this
i owed everybody i knew money
but the guy that
told me he said don't clean officer for
somebody else do them for yourself and
he told me where i could buy a used
floor machine and some buckets and mops
it was going to cost 980
i mean i didn't know anyone would lend
me money because i never pay them back
not that i didn't want to i just never
had any money
well i searched and searched and
searched and i found a guy that lent me
a thousand dollars
so when somebody tells me they can't
borrow money i know that they haven't
tried
i think anybody can borrow a thousand
dollars somewhere
and that's what i did
and i turned it into a multi-million
dollar organization
i sat down one day with my pen
in this business i said i'm going to
build a company that operates all over
the world we operate all over the world
so if you have to borrow money
borrow the money
but get into the business
actually do it you know the truth is
your spiritual dna
is perfect
we hear a lot of talk about dna today
well if you get past all the nonsense
that's been programmed into our
subconscious mind from genetics and in
our environment
and get right down to the core of who
you really are
your spiritual dna is perfect and it's
that perfection that's seeking
expression with and through us
that's why we want things it doesn't
matter what we're doing we want more
now as a little boy i was taught by my
grandmother who pretty well raised me
that you should be satisfied with what
you've got
grandma was a dear woman she was like an
angel of god but she was wrong we should
never be satisfied with what we've got
we should be happy with what we've got
but never satisfied
you see dissatisfaction is a creative
state for our mind to move into
it causes us to want to do more
we should ask ourselves where those
wants come from do you know what's that
perfection within that keeps jabbing you
in the consciousness want this want that
if you're running you'll want to run
faster if you're jumping you want to
jump higher if you're selling you want
to sell more if you're singing you want
to sing a better tune
it doesn't really matter what you're
doing
you want to do it better
and the beautiful part of this is you
can i'm going to share something with
you that could change the course of your
life could make everything so much
better to do this to explain it properly
i'm going to tell you a little story he
goes way back 57 years
a man gave me this book he said bob do
exactly what i tell you and you can have
anything you want now when he said that
i was flat broke
i had six thousand dollars in debt and i
was only earning four thousand dollars a
year the prospects of thing getting
better were pretty slim
i had two months high school formal
education i had absolutely no business
experience i was not in a good spot but
he said listen there are reasons why you
can't win bob he said if you do what i
tell you and study this book
is you're going to figure out how you
can now this is napoleon hill's book
think and grow rich he spent his whole
life studying 500 of the world's most
successful individuals and he found
there was a golden thread running
through their life and that's what's in
this book i've never stopped reading it
i then found a condensed narration of
the book by earl nightingale where earl
took and he condensed the whole thing
and he put it on a long playing record
and i would listen to that and listen to
it and listen to it in fact i had
started my own company and i used to
play the records to the sales people
every morning
well one morning it was very early
just finished the salesman and just
finished playing earl's record and i
said at the end of the meeting i said
man i'd really love to meet him one of
the sales people said no you wouldn't
he's what do you mean i wouldn't he said
if you really wanted to meet him you'd
go and meet him and it's like you know
something you're right i got on the
phone and i got an appointment with earl
[ __ ] now that wasn't an easy thing to
do earl was the most listened to men in
the history of the broadcasting industry
at the time earl nightingale lloyd conan
started the night galconi corporation
who literally started the personal
development business as we know it today
in recorded fashion he was considered
the dean of personal motivation there
was probably a couple of million people
that would have loved to sat down with
him but i got the appointment at the end
of the meeting i had a wonderful time
there when i was leaving i said earl
what is the big deal what is the real
secret of like to making things happen
well he said there isn't any secret to
success bob he said it's a simple matter
of figuring out what you absolutely love
to do
and then make a decision to dedicate
your life to it then every day you're
going to be doing what you love to do so
the problem with most people is they
never decide what they love to do and
they don't make a decision to dedicate
their life to anything they just go from
one thing to the next people have
regrets i mean if you want to go to
nursing home
and just feel that for a half for a
minute if you're looking through their
eyes you can see there's regret well
most people do but most people don't do
anything
you see i often say how do you do
something
well there's where the goals come in
that's where the purpose for life comes
in
you're going to have a main purpose you
got to have a purpose for life and
you've got to have meaningful goals
they've got to be meaningful you're
trading your life for it
like i often say in a seminar
i want you to imagine you're at the end
of the road
and you know you're at the end of the
road
your body's so weak
they've got you tied in a wheelchair
or they've got you in a crib bed
so you don't follow
kill yourself right
just imagine all you can do is relive
your life
i want you to imagine
you're there
and you go back and think i wonder if we
had a move there what would have
happened if we hadn't started that
company remember we're going to
sell the house and start that company if
we hadn't done this i wonder what would
have happened and then cut if i could
only do it over again
i said wouldn't that be terrible
spend the last days of your life like
that wouldn't it be better
if you look back and say wow what a trip
gotta remember we did that remember we
blew our brains out on that we lost
everything we had
but you know
when you lose it big enough it can be
accelerating and then we did this and
what you're doing is laying there and
you're reliving your whole life
and that's the goal got to have the goal
i'm always asked how do you stay so
young
and i tell them i don't hang around to
all people and i said that i think sort
of as a joke one time
but then i realized it was no joke it's
the truth
i um
i don't mix with anybody my age i'm 85
years old in july
and
so i was born in 1934
that's a long time ago
and
i don't go by age of anything
i become aware that age is
it's a number
and it has nothing to do with who we are
what we're going to do when we clearly
understand that our life will change you
know the idea of 65 for retirement is
pretty well accepted worldwide
and it was accepted by otto von bismarck
when he was chancellor at germany
somebody said you know we should have an
age where people can stop working the
government just send them a check he
said that's a hell of a good idea so he
just arbitrarily picked 65.
well a number of years later when they
were going to do it in america they said
is anybody doing that they said i think
they're doing in germany what age 65 and
it's accepted 65 is age of retirement
[Music]
why would we want to retire at all
seeing ibc retire as pulled back from
life that's what it means
why would we want to do that i never
want to do it i never want to retire i
think that would be a despicable thing
to do when people go into forced
retirement in nothing flat they're dead
you see
when i'm made for work work is made for
us
and when we clearly understand that
um i think things start to change for us
i um i think people should ask
themselves how old would they be if they
forgot their age if i forgot my age i
think i'd be around 48.
maybe not even 50. 47 48 maybe 46.
um i like the late 40s i think they're
good years
i think that's how old i'd be
and i lived like that's where i am
the idea of slowing down or
[Applause]
that's just so foreign to my way of
thinking
i i don't i don't think that way
and
the idea of retirement it'll never
happen to me
i'm going gonna go full tilt
right until the show's over
that's my attitude towards it i don't
hang around all people most old people
are old people
and they talk about old things and on
their rim and this thing all the time we
ought to believe that we're creative
beings and there's nowhere we haven't
gone that we can't go
so let's get up and get moving that's my
attitude and age
why did a guy like me change
i didn't believe there was an emotional
or capricious god reached out and said
let's give bob a chance
i didn't believe that
i thought
something's happened what's happened
well i spent nine and a half years
studying
with some absolutely brilliant people
now i formed a good habit over that time
i picked good mentors and that's very
important
you can use these films as a mentor you
can you can let me be your mentor
general i've often heard it said people
that have been gone for a couple of
thousand years can help you more than
somebody that's alive today and i get a
lot of help from people that have been
gone for a long time through their books
and writings so you could use this
series as a mentor
[Music]
but a habit i formed
right from the first person that helped
me
ray
ray stanford he said do exactly what i
tell you
and for some reason i decided i would
i didn't question him i just did it he
said do it until you find out i'm lying
or i don't know what i'm talking about
[Music]
and he said i don't lie
and i do know what i'm talking about so
i'm going to say that to you and
hopefully you'll grasp it the same as i
did
do what i suggest in these films until
you find out i'm lying or i don't know
what i'm talking about i don't lie
and believe me i do know what i'm
talking about
many years ago they said by their right
results you'll know them or by their
fruit you'll know them i searched every
day and every time i picked a new mentor
and i did pick new mentors i did exactly
what they said
it was difficult at first because what i
was really doing was changing habit
patterns
but they were teaching me things they
were teaching me
information that the average person may
never learn
i developed a very close rapport with
them
and they were brilliant people every one
of them very accomplished
[Music]
that is a good rule if you want to do
something go to someone who is
demonstrated by results they do know
what they're talking about ask them what
should you do
then do exactly what they tell you
now i know that works
because i'm still doing it
and i do it every day
i have found there's two forms of income
in life one is psychic
the psychic income and that's the
satisfaction we get from how we spend
our days the other is our material
income the money we earn and it's the
money we earn that permits us to do the
things we want to do and go we want to
go and live the way we really want to
live so if a person is living the way
they really want to live i believe they
need an abundance of both sources of
income they need a lot of money because
it costs a lot of money to live today
and they need a lot of satisfaction well
you know i don't know any way you can
get more satisfaction than you can by
sitting down and helping another person
figure out exactly what they want to do
and then share the information with them
that gives them the courage and the
confidence and the calmness in their
character to step out and do what they
really want to do
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there